tollé mammoni alors si on a tous de quoi
va-t-on parler aujourd'hui salut
alexandre je vais te faire découvrir la
cmu tu sais ce que fait la chine quoi la
serbie alexandre sur l'a4 mobilité
inclusion mais ne t'inquiète pas c'est
super simple est super pratique tu vas
voir si vous aussi cette carte vous
intéresse rester avec moi
[Musique]
la serbie c'est le petit nom de la carte
mobilité inclusion cette carte peut être
utilisée par les personnes âgées ou
handicapées ce dispositif département
d'un doigt plusieurs avantages vous
allez entendre
judiciaire bonjour à quoi est faite la
carte mobilité inclusion la cad mobilité
un qu'ils ont eue hier matin et d'être
reconnus handicapés de passer plus vite
dans comme on dit à l'hôpital
supermarché on prouve que on est
handicapé les difficiles qu'on l'ait pas
voyant on considère pas toujours
handicapé justement soit pas 7 4
l'important pour mais la cades va facile
à moins d'être visible visible auprès
des gens visible auprès de la société
ces 4 life permet de montrer voilà je
suis pas bien mais regardez je me bats
quand même et je voudrais aller plus
loin quels sont les avantages de 7,4
d'autres quotidiens à mon droit mon
doigt de personnes handicapées syrien
que l'apparence physique et wap à
l'intérieur mais sa c4 la paix méthodes
vont à l'intérieur du lydia
[Musique]
depuis 2010 est le département se charge
de délivrer la scène 7,4 décline en
trois motions la validité la priorité et
le stationnement chacune de ces quatre
facilitent le quotidien de ses
bénéficiaires
bonjour ma jolie jean marronniers quels
avantages offre les 3 cartes de mobilité
inclusion donc nous avons trois cartes
dossier me classer mes priorités
invalidité et stationnement la cmu
stationnement c'est pour les places de
parking la cni priorité c'est pour les
files d'attentes lorsque la personne est
en station debout pénible et la ceni
invalidité ai fait office de priorité
mais également la personne a droit à une
demi part d'impôts supplémentaires et
l'attribution aux logements sociaux et
justement tu es sur les démarches assez
pour pouvoir bénéficier de ces cartes
nous d'éviter inclusion il ya deux
portes d'entrée les mdph ou lazare donc
la mdph c'est pour les personnes qui ont
moins de 60 ans ou les personnes qui ont
plus de 60 ans mais qui n'ont pas
d'appétit et pour lazard c'est pour les
personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans qui
bénéficient de la paix à ou qui sont
demandeurs d'appétit majoré je t'en prie
bras cassé et mais les bénéficiaires sur
prioritaire dans le transport en commun
dans les files d'attentes ou en projet
les places de parking sont disposés ci
profite aussi à leurs accompagnants avec
des tartes le déplacement sont beaucoup
plus simple et surtout plus agréable
bonjour judiciaire je mens jury alors
depuis la dernière foire à ben depuis la
dernière fois avec ma carte là permettez
moi de valoir mes droits l'accord est
cette carte elle elle est vraiment utile
pour ton quotidien vie pour mon
quotidien lui pour montrer que me les
handicapés que ça se voit pas mais les
la la carte club c'est une clé à à la
smac les white guérilla mes droits la
corde bon ben je te dis à bientôt à
bientôt
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur la scène n'hésitez
pas vous avez tous tes coordonnées qui
s'affiche à votre écran le département
des générations c'est fini si vous
souhaitez ou avoir cet épisode ainsi
quid des deux précédents rendez vous sur
nos sites et aux eaux sociaux quant à
moi je me retrouve très vite pas un
nouvel épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous invite à
découvrir l'aide au transport scolaire
des élèves et étudiants handicapés grâce
à ce dispositif du département ce sont
environ 1800 jeunes qui peuvent accéder
à un véhicule pour se rendre à l'école
au collège au lycée ou encore à
l'université
[Musique]